foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
something like that
random noodling
all right folks the question has been
posed about the chicken and the Pickin
Chicken picking
I've got many tutorials out on this and
what's interesting is that people are
like
how you do that chicken picking thing
and then these watch videos and they're
like it's so hard well it's not easy if
it was easy everyone would do it but I
mean it it's it's easy but it's not
simple so it takes a while to do it's
not something that's good I mean some
people get the initial concept right
away but to be able to do it you got to
put the time in and uh and there's a
degree of physical uh discomfort when uh
doing this stuff it's it's something
that initially you can get but the more
you do it
whether you do it with the thumb and
fingers like I'm going to show you or do
it with picking fingers there is
um soreness that's going to happen with
the thumb and the fingers and nails
break and the whole nine yards
so it is a
it's a voyage that you start off on that
never really ends and uh so don't be
discouraged earlier on it's going to
take a while in order to do this thing
and so the idea of chicken picking I
mean I first got into it
[Music]
just that idea that
that sound I heard Mark Knopfler do uh
you know
[Music]
that kind of a thing or we can just bend
one string and go
[Laughter]
[Music]
the chicken picking there is the actual
chicken pick which is just this idea of
doing a muted note
immediately after or before an actual
note okay so this mute note regular note
mute note regular note that gives us
kind of this sound
then there's just the physicality of
just popping the strings gives it the
sound of
that kind of playing that I think people
uh respond to or they think oh that's
chicken picking you know just popping
the strings and so on and so forth so
let me just kind of show you
a few different things that you can do
to do all of the above right
um the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to show you with my pick and
finger because that's where I first
learned to do this I would actually just
stash my pick in between my first and
middle fingers here and kind of go back
and forth
between using the pick and not
so when I would do the chicken pick and
I'd stash my pick in between my first
and middle finger and then I would just
have the idea of using my thumb and
first finger to just kind of grab the
strings and pop them but the idea of a
chicken pick is the idea of a muted note
as I said either before or after a
regular note so just to show you for the
I've done this a million times but I'm
going to show it again
um
if I'm on the a string of the guitar
with my right hand I'm going to put my
first finger down on the a string my
thumb's going down on the same string so
both my first finger and my thumb are on
the a string okay so what happens is I
pluck a note nothing's really going on
with my right hand at this point other
than some muting but I'm going to have
my thumb pluck a note that's muted
because my first finger is right behind
it so you just get a big old thud
but then I'm going to actually use that
first finger on the a string and kind of
lift the string up a little bit and pop
it
so between the thud and the pop the
chicken takes flight so you gotta go
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so if I just grab one string I'm
driving the G string here
bending it up at the fourth fret of Jose
I'm doing the same thing not my first
fingers on the G string my thumbs on the
G string
[Laughter]
now when I'm doing that stuff it sounds
like I'm chicken picking but I'm really
doing is I'm just kind of observing a
thing where my first finger look here is
on the G string of my thumbs on the D
string so you just kind of alternate to
where you need to be where the thumb is
hitting the lower string and your first
finger is reaching the higher strings
I'm just doing like eight pentatonic
stuff here
oh
so that right there
happening there on the G string
but the rest of it I'm just going back
and forth between the first finger and
the thumb
[Music]
[Laughter]
all that stuff right there was just
thumb and First Finger on adjacent
strings that gives it that sound because
I'm popping up the string
there's a little bit of muting going on
the left hand as well
now there's this Rhythm pattern that
Mark Knopfler used to do that's super
cool and what I'm basically doing with
this is I'm doing the um chicken pick on
the a string
I'm hitting an a chord down here so the
thumb and First Finger are on the a
string
the middle finger on my right hand is
going to be on the D string
my third finger on my right hand is
going to be on the G string and I'm
going back and forth
[Music]
I also do a variation of the magic Sam
lick which is the Lego
foreign
between that my version of it
what's Magic Sam does is that he does a
version of what's the thumb and the
first finger but because he's popping
the strings it sounds like chicken
so there my first finger is just hitting
the G string and my thumb's going in
between them
draping my left hand over the strings of
the muting
[Music]
so that gives the sound of chicken
picking but again the idea of chicken
picking is this muted thing and popping
the strings so there is science behind
it in terms of what I showed you with
the being on the same string and doing
that
but sometimes it's just a matter of a
thumb being on a lower string and your
first finger being on a higher string
and popping
so that's with the thumb and the fingers
so I had to learn to do it with the pick
and the fingers and the hybrid picking
technique this took me a while so don't
think it's like oh I'll just I mean you
may be a super learner
be able to do it in in scant moments but
there's some physicality behind it that
just takes a while for you to get muscle
memory and all that other kind of stuff
going so
if initially you can't do it it's not a
surprise it takes a long time and it's
painful because it took me a long time
because I would as I said I would go
between doing my regular flat picking
and doing the chicken picking this way
because the idea of doing chicken
picking with the pick and finger
together was very daunting because
everyone I was into from James Burton to
Danny Gatton to Albert Lee to Roy
Buchanan all those guys use pick and
fingers together and to me it was very
difficult to make the transition
because basically what you're doing is
doing the same thing you're doing with
the thumb and fingers as far as what I
was just doing the basic initial chicken
pick is of you know I have a little bit
of a nail people always ask do I use you
know synthetic nails do I use anything
on my nails I do not as I find that if I
just have a little bit of white showing
above the cuticle I got enough to pop
the string so there's barely I just
broke my nail the other day and I broke
it a little bit so I did a file to make
it smooth again but once it's smooth it
as long as I got a little bit of a nail
I got enough to pop the string so in
this instance what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put that middle finger now
with that little bit of nail on the a
string and the pick is going on the same
string
and I'm doing the pick it's a note
that's muted and then I'm popping up
with that middle finger
brighter side
so again if I go to the G string now and
bend it up at the fourth fret
again my my middle finger and pick are
on the G string
doing that same kind of lick but now
that first one is the chicken
but the rest is I'm kind of doing what I
did with my thumb and First Finger but
now I've got the pick on the lower
string and my middle finger on the
higher string
[Music]
so every time I'm using that middle
finger I'm kind of lifting up the string
a little bit and popping it
doing uh
a little bit of black chicken
anyways you get the idea so there it is
that's some chicken picking exercises
for you uh I hope that helps foreign
[Music]
picking Travis picking is not uh
something that came natural to me
um
most of the people that I knew that did
Travis picking usually had it run in the
family there was like an uncle or a
a father or brother that knew how to
play kind of in the Merle Travis Chet
Atkins School of stuff
um and uh I only got into it when I went
into college and uh and I started to get
into chat because I was really into
Albert Lee and that led me into
different places
um but the idea of Travis picking I
remember when I first learned everyone
thought the Travis like
which is one version of Travis picking
[Music]
that kind of a thing but really the
Travis picking that I heard uh that
sounded so cool was the idea of just
this it almost sounds like a stride
piano like a
[Music]
h
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
so the idea is uh I think the best way
to start it is just with kind of the
Mystery Train lick uh because the idea
is the the pick is always doing this
I used to think it had to go always go
like E string D string a string E string
it doesn't have to it just needs to go
sometimes it's doing that but for the
most part you just need that boom Chuck
thing happening of like a stride piano
player right uh so most of the time
people do this with a thumb pick
and um
it's easier with a thumb pick you've got
gravity working for you that thumb pick
is going like this and gravity is
helping you when you're using a pick and
fingers together it's a little bit more
difficult but by the time I got into
this style I was not willing to ditch
all the things that I do with a flat
pick to play with the thumb pick or to
go back and forth I just didn't want to
do that so
I force myself to learn how to do it in
an acceptable way in my life anyway
um
with the pick and the fingers so uh let
me show you a little bit of how we can
again this is something that's going to
take a while so don't get discouraged
um but typically what happens is people
want to just learn this too fast and
they start doing and they realize
they're not hitting they start going
instead of going
because this has got to be going the
whole time
can't speed it up
uh until you can do it in Tempo at
whatever Tempo that is it might be just
like one
[Music]
whatever it takes just don't speed it up
until you can do that consistently so
the idea is I'm using my middle finger
on the B string of my right hand
I'm sorry my third finger on my right
hand is on the B string my middle finger
is on the G string and my pick is
actually
is dealing with the E string and the D
string I'm ignoring the a string right
now
so that's basically what's happening
with the right hand
[Music]
it goes It goes between these two
patterns
that's the with the right hand you're
going
over here I'm doing e do a little hammer
on to a
I'm using some palm muting with my right
hand
[Music]
now one thing I've noticed with this is
that
what you're going to find is is that
your fingers plucking are actually going
to be louder than your pick so then the
the Temptation is to want to then pick
harder
meet somewhere in the middle because
what you want to do is if you're if your
fingers are popping too loud just don't
pop them as hard and find an equal
ground with your pick so that they sound
even
[Music]
okay and there's going to be pain
involved I'm sorry but it's it's going
to hurt but if you try not to play so
hard because that's the one of the
things I gotta
play it really loud and
don't be concerned with that just try to
keep the notes even
but even so you're going to have some
blistering and some things going on with
your right hand that are unpleasant but
then once you get used to doing it
calluses build up and and
um and all of a sudden you'll be okay
but
there is some initial sticker shock to
this these kind of activities and again
it takes a while but that basic template
or that
[Music]
in the right hand
it's the basic Travis picking thing that
I do so if I'm doing it like up here now
I'm switching it around to I've got um
my middle finger on the high E string
and my middle finger on the B string
[Music]
I'm going like this
so I'm doing like a13 I'm ignoring the a
string again so I got
actually it's an A9
okay
[Music]
we're getting slots
that's going to take a while to get down
and do it slow don't speed it up until
you can get this has got to be going the
whole time
thank you
[Music]
you're Off to the Races
that's your Travis picking mini tutorial
good luck
[Music]
[Laughter]